Ti parlerò di una palla che ruota, tranne che non è una palla e non sta ruotando. Oggi in Qiskit in the
classroom parleremo di questa proprietà quantistica chiamata spin, osservando l'esperimento che ne ha trovato le prime evidenze.
Benvenuto a Qiskit in the classroom. In questa serie useremo Qiskit per esplorare alcuni concetti fondamentali comunemente
trattati nei corsi legati al Quantum Computing. Ogni video sarà accompagnato da un modulo interattivo
collegato nella descrizione qui sotto, quindi assicurati di controllarlo. Oggi parliamo dell'esperimento di Stern-Gerlach del 1922.
È uno dei più famosi nella storia della teoria quantistica perché dimostra in modo così evidente come funziona lo spin quantistico.
Ma non era questo che Stern o Gerlach intendevano dimostrare. L'esperimento era progettato per mettere alla prova un nuovo modello quantistico
dell'atomo chiamato modello di Bohr, dal nome di Niels Bohr che lo propose nel 1913. In quel modello gli elettroni orbita vano
intorno al nucleo in orbitali discreti e potevano passare da un orbitale all'altro assorbendo o emettendo
fotoni. Ogni orbitale aveva un momento angolare quantizzato che era un multiplo intero di una piccola costante fondamentale
chiamata H. Negli anni '10 e nei primi anni '20, la meccanica quantistica era del tutto nuova, così nuova
che non veniva ancora chiamata meccanica quantistica. Quindi non tutti erano convinti del modello di Bohr. Un fisico
di nome Otto Stern lo odiava. Chiamò il modello una sciocchezza e arrivò persino a minacciare di abbandonare la fisica se Bohr avesse avuto
ragione. Stern era così determinato a dimostrare che il modello fosse sbagliato che trovò un modo ingegnoso per metterlo alla prova e
reclutò Walther Gerlach per aiutarlo a progettare e condurre l'esperimento. Si scoprì che non riuscì a dimostrare che Bohr avesse torto: finì
per dimostrare che aveva torto lui stesso. Il loro esperimento era così semplice e i risultati così netti che sostanzialmente chiuse il
dibattito: la meccanica quantistica governa alla scala atomica. Non se ne resero conto all'epoca,
ma l'esperimento di Stern e Gerlach trovò anche prove conclusive dello spin intrinseco dell'elettrone, una
nuova proprietà fondamentale della natura essenziale per spiegare il magnetismo, la superconduttività e gran parte della
chimica. Oggi ti mostrerò come funziona l'esperimento di Stern-Gerlach, cosa ci aspetteremmo classicamente di vedere
dall'esperimento e cosa Stern e Gerlach trovarono effettivamente. Poi ti mostrerò come puoi eseguire il tuo esperimento di tipo Stern-Gerlach
con Qiskit e un computer quantistico IBM. L'idea di base dell'esperimento di Stern-Gerlach
era trovare un modo per determinare se il momento angolare di un elettrone in un atomo fosse quantizzato come
prevedeva Bohr, oppure no come si aspettava Stern. Usarono il fatto che il momento angolare dell'elettrone avrebbe anche causato la presenza
di un piccolo campo magnetico intorno a ogni atomo. Quindi puoi pensarli come piccoli magneti a barra.
L'esperimento era fatto così: c'era un forno pieno di atomi di argento
e un campo magnetico con i poli Nord e Sud
qui. Il campo era più forte vicino alla parte superiore e più debole vicino alla parte inferiore, producendo un gradiente verso l'alto.
Infine c'era uno schermo. Nell'esperimento il forno riscaldava gli atomi di argento fino a farli evaporare e poi
uscivano dal forno con l'orientamento del piccolo magnete a barra di ogni atomo completamente casuale. Poi gli atomi
attraversavano il campo magnetico. Gli atomi venivano spinti verso l'alto o verso il basso con una forza che dipendeva dalla direzione del
polo Nord di ogni atomo rispetto al gradiente del campo. Poi gli atomi colpivano lo schermo. Stern e Gerlach potevano osservare
dove gli atomi colpivano lo schermo per capire il momento angolare degli elettroni. Stern si aspettava che gli atomi
nell'esperimento si comportassero come li ho descritti fino ad ora: come piccoli magneti a barra che obbediscono alle
regole della fisica classica. Classicamente questi piccoli magneti atomici potevano essere orientati in qualsiasi direzione casuale, quindi mentre
attraversavano il campo magnetico potevano sperimentare una gamma di forze diverse che li spingevano su o giù a seconda di quegli orientamenti. Un magnete
che punta nella stessa direzione del gradiente avrebbe subito una grande forza verso l'alto, nella direzione opposta avrebbe
subito una grande forza verso il basso, e se fosse stato nel mezzo sarebbe stata una forza più debole. Se l'atomo puntasse
perpendicolarmente al gradiente non avrebbe subito alcuna forza e sarebbe continuato dritto. A causa di questa
gamma di forze possibili, gli atomi avrebbero dovuto colpire lo schermo in punti verticali diversi. Il pattern che avrebbero creato
sullo schermo sarebbe stato qualcosa del genere. Ma non è quello che Stern e
Gerlach videro. Invece videro due macchie di atomi completamente separate sullo schermo, senza atomi nel
centro. Non avevano la teoria corretta per spiegarlo all'epoca, ma ora sappiamo che videro questo perché
ogni elettrone ha una certa quantità di momento angolare intrinseco sotto forma di spin, che può assumere solo
uno di due valori. Nella nostra immagine del magnete a barra questo significa che ci sono solo due orientamenti consentiti per i magneti atomici. Chiamiamo
questi due orientamenti spin up e spin down. Un qubit in un computer quantistico
assomiglia a questo tipo di sistema di spin e alcuni computer quantistici usano effettivamente qubit costituiti dallo spin elettronico.
Possiamo quindi eseguire il nostro esperimento di Stern-Gerlach con Qiskit e i qubit di un computer quantistico IBM.
Mappiamo lo stato spin up dell'elettrone sullo stato zero del qubit e lo stato spin down sullo stato uno
del qubit. Quando le particelle di argento uscivano dal forno avevano momenti magnetici orientati casualmente.
Possiamo modellare l'esperimento di Stern-Gerlach creando un semplice circuit quantistico con un singolo qubit che parte dallo stato zero.
Questo è un diagramma del circuit dove il filo in alto è il qubit e le operazioni applicate al qubit
appaiono come riquadri sul filo. I riquadri RX e RZ sono gate quantistici che
ruotano effettivamente l'orientamento magnetico dell'atomo. Possiamo scegliere valori casuali per Theta e F qui per ruotare il
qubit di una quantità casuale. Questo imita il forno che espelle gli atomi con orientamenti di spin casuali. Il riquadro grigio è
la nostra misurazione. Ci dice se il qubit è nello stato zero o uno e invia quella misurazione a un bit classico,
la doppia linea etichettata C. Questa parte equivale a misurare se l'atomo è in spin up o spin down guardando in quale
punto colpisce lo schermo. Possiamo usare una primitiva di Qiskit chiamata sampler per eseguire l'esperimento molte volte, ognuna con
valori casuali diversi per Theta e F. Dopo 100 campioni otteniamo un istogramma delle misurazioni che appare così. Circa
il 50% delle volte il qubit viene misurato come zero e il 50% delle volte è nello stato 1. Questo è lo stesso risultato che Stern
e Gerlach ottennero: è sempre o spin up o spin down, mai nel mezzo. A questo punto potresti pensare: beh,
certo che abbiamo ottenuto due risultati discreti: abbiamo eseguito l'esperimento su un computer quantistico digitale che restituisce sempre
zero o uno. Ed è vero. Ma tieni presente che l'intera ragione per cui i computer quantistici restituiscono risultati binari, in effetti
il motivo per cui il Quantum Computing funziona del tutto, è esattamente questa quantizzazione dello spin che Stern e Gerlach scoprirono per la prima volta.
I qubit dei computer quantistici IBM non si basano sugli spin, ma molti altri computer quantistici lo fanno. Quindi eseguire un
esperimento di Stern-Gerlach su un computer quantistico ci permette di riscoprire effettivamente la quantizzazione dello spin.
Dal 1922 sono state eseguite innumerevoli estensioni all'esperimento originale di Stern-Gerlach. Queste estensioni implicano
l'invio dello stesso fascio di atomi attraverso più apparati di Stern-Gerlach per vedere come si comportano gli spin in diversi
scenari. Eccone uno: inviamo gli atomi attraverso un apparato per separare il fascio in due parti corrispondenti a un
fascio spin up e un fascio spin down, e poi inviamo ciascuno di quei fasci attraverso il proprio
apparato separato. Con Qiskit il circuit quantistico corrispondente a questo esperimento è simile all'ultimo ma con due
misurazioni invece di una. Qui abbiamo sostituito le rotazioni casuali che imitavano l'effetto del forno con un
gate chiamato Hadamard, poiché applicare il Hadamard ci darà le stesse probabilità di misurazione del forno
ma è molto più semplice da usare. Quindi misuriamo una volta e poi due volte, e il
risultante istogramma delle misurazioni appare così, dove le stringhe di bit sull'asse X corrispondono ai
risultati delle due misurazioni. Se il qubit è stato misurato zero entrambe le volte, corrisponde alla stringa di bit 0 0, oppure se
è stato misurato prima zero poi uno, corrisponde a uno zero e così via. Sembra che se viene misurato spin up nel
primo esperimento, sarà spin up anche nel secondo. Lo stesso vale per gli atomi spin down. Questo significa che nel primo esperimento
avevamo uguale probabilità di misurare su o giù, ma al secondo esperimento il risultato era già determinato. Quindi i
due schermi alla fine di ciascuno dei secondi apparati di Stern-Gerlach avrebbero ciascuno solo un punto. Uno schermo avrebbe
tutti gli atomi spin up e uno schermo avrebbe tutti gli atomi spin down. Per il nostro prossimo esperimento,
partiamo con un fascio di atomi puramente spin up. Con un vero esperimento fisico di Stern-Gerlach potresti farlo inviandoli
attraverso un apparato di Stern-Gerlach e bloccando il fascio che viene deflesso verso il basso, in modo che tutti gli atomi deflessi verso l'alto siano
spin up. Ora inviamo questo fascio attraverso un altro apparato di Stern-Gerlach, ma questa volta ruotiamo i magneti di 90° in modo
che il gradiente del campo defletta gli atomi che viaggiano in questo modo verso sinistra o verso destra. Vedremmo
un punto o due, o qualcosa di completamente diverso? Per questo esperimento
eseguiremo il circuit seguente su Qiskit. Partiremo dallo stato zero poiché il nostro fascio di atomi in questo esperimento è tutto
spin up. Poi questo gate Hadamard scambia le coordinate x e z in modo da avere l'effetto di ruotare
l'apparato di Stern-Gerlach. Ora stiamo misurando la proiezione dello spin a sinistra o a destra invece di su o giù. Qui otteniamo
l'istogramma delle misurazioni che appare così. Possiamo vedere che lo spin lungo X può assumere anch'esso solo due valori,
che possiamo chiamare spin sinistra e spin destra. Quindi questo esperimento mostra che se misuri la proiezione X di uno spin
che era stato precedentemente misurato come spin up lungo Z, sarà spin sinistra o destra con uguale probabilità. Confrontiamo
un'ultima volta con l'aspettativa classica solo per evidenziare davvero la differenza. Classicamente ricorda che
ho detto che se il piccolo magnete a barra atomico puntava perpendicolarmente al gradiente del campo magnetico dell'apparato,
la forza su quell'atomo dovrebbe essere zero. Non dovrebbe essere deflesso su o giù. In quel caso vedremmo solo un singolo punto al
centro dello schermo. Invece vediamo due punti. Quindi metà degli atomi hanno spin sinistra e metà hanno spin destra, nonostante
fossero stati precedentemente misurati come up. Quindi da una prospettiva meccanica quantistica, sebbene possa essere tentante
equiparare spin up a un vettore che punta verso l'alto e spin down a uno che punta verso il basso, non è così semplice, come possiamo vedere
dall'ultimo esperimento. Per capire davvero cosa sta succedendo qui dovremo approfondire i temi della
sovrapposizione quantistica e della misurazione, che sarà argomento di un altro video. Proprio come siamo rimasti con più
domande su come funziona esattamente la meccanica quantistica, così furono Stern e Gerlach. Il loro esperimento non spiegò
tutto, ma contribuì notevolmente a stabilire la meccanica quantistica come essenziale per comprendere il mondo naturale.
Fu uno degli esperimenti fondazionali più importanti della meccanica quantistica, che sia provò la quantizzazione
del momento sia fornì prove di una nuova proprietà fondamentale della natura chiamata spin. Per confrontarsi davvero con
e comprendere le regole del mondo quantistico, fisici come Stern e Gerlach dovettero sporcarsi le mani progettando
esperimenti, facendo previsioni e a volte sbagliando. Non c'è davvero alcun sostituto al provare le cose da soli.
Quindi se vuoi cimentarti nell'esecuzione di veri esperimenti quantistici, vai al modulo di Stern-Gerlach
collegato nella descrizione. Grazie per aver guardato e ci vediamo la prossima volta.